hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to  the show you may all know me as Lady  gaga but tonight I am lady haha  Lady Gaga took over the Late Late Show  with James Corden Tuesday night to tell  some jokes and more importantly deliver  one heck of an installment of carpool  karaoke the duo drove around la singing  their hearts out including Gaga's hits  past and present there were plenty of  unexpected moments too like when James  let Gaga take the wheel  despite her lack of driving experience  God you learnt like the hand signals to  drive in ooh yeah this one and then  there was an impromptu Gaga inspired  fashion show where James showed off some  of the singers most iconic couture  creations  good thing with this one is you've  always got a snug but this is Gaga we're  talking about here so you know they had  to end on a powerful musical note a  hundred  young reason to walk away maybe I just  need one good one to stay  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]